اثر شكل سلبي جدا بالمقوله اللي اخذها من
حسن البنا حلال وحلال وحرام وحرام اللي
ساعات كتير ناس لما تقول لما لغايه دلوقتي
حتى لو مره شفت اشرف زكي نقيب الممثلين
المصريين قال ازاي يقولوا الفن حرام ده
انا قعدت مع الشيخ الشعراوي وقال حلال
وحلال وحرام وحرام يا جماعه لو قلت كده
المرجعيه بقت ايه بقت الدين مش كده كلمه
حلال وحرام هي في الترمومتر بتاعك ايه
الدين الفن ليس له علاقه كمقيال بمقياس
الدين زي ما تقول لي انه الزلزال بالقيس
الزلزال بايه ريختر هل بالقيسه بدرجه
الحراره العادي لا كل حاجه لها مقياس الفن
طب مقياسه ايه الجمال والقبح علم
الاستاتيكا هل الفن ضد ضد الاخلاق لا
الجمال نقيسه بعلم الفن نقيسه بعلم الجمال
علمي لصديقه علم الجمال وبالتالي وبالتالي
لما تقول لي حلال وحلال وحرام وحرام فانت
قصته المرجعيه عندك بقت اخلاقيه ودينيه
السؤال التاني هل الفن ضد الدين والاخلاق
اقول لك لا برضو ما فيش فن بيتعمل عشان
يضرب اخلاق او يضرب ثقافه او يضرب قيمه بس
الفن له معايير اخرى لما بدا يربي عند
الناس مثلا يقابله حسن يوسف كويس حسن كان
من المغرمين به
فقال له انت حسن غلط
اه بيسالوا يا مولانا انا بتجوز في
الافلام اتجوز كتير حسن المشاهد تمثيليه
يعني كثير قال له لا حرام لا في حديث ما
معناها جده جد
فقالوا لا حرام قال له طب ازاي بقى كده
قال له بص بقى من هنا ورايحه انت عرفت ان
ده حرام ما تعملهاش تاني طيب غير كده قال
له حاجه ثانيه قال له انت علمت الناس في
شبابك قال له انا بطل تمثيل قال له لا قال
له علمت الناس في شبابك اللهو والضحك
واللعب مع البنات علمهم بقى الالتزام فطلع
من عنده يقول انا مش معتزل انا ملتزم
طب حاجه في النص كده هل الممثل ما يعملش
الادوار طيب وكذا حسن عابدين نفس الحكايه
لما بيقابلوه ما بيقولوش فن حرام او بطلوا
فن لكن بيقول لهم فن بمعايير معينه تقتل
الفن ده اللي انا بختلف فيه مع الشيخ
الشعراوي بحترمه كداعيه بحترم اجتهاده في
تفسير القران لكن بختلف مع مع الكثير من
افكاره لما يصلي لله شكر بعد 67 انت كعربي
ممكن مهما كان في خلافات كانت موجوده زمان
في الستينيات من نظام عبد الناصر وفي
الملك سعود هل ممكن تتبسط ان مصر تهزم
طبعا
رايحه ناحيه الشيوعيه وانا قلت كويس طب
والدماء اللي اريقت
وتهديد الامن المصري ما هو هينعكس كمان
يعني
عايز اقول اذا ما فكرناش
مش ممكن ده يبقى فكر فانا بختلف معاه في
الافكار دي ما ليش علاقه به كداعيه فعشان
كده الامور اتلخبطت عند الناس كثير قوي
وحد بيترفع عليها دعوه الزراعه اديان وحتى
احد ابناؤه قال لك هو انت تعرف ربنا عشان
يعني حتى بيتهمك في علاقتك بربنا احد
الشعراوي كتب كده عليا يعني عايز اقول كان
في مبالغات ردود فعل مبالغه جدا في انه اي
كلام متعلق بافكار وليس تفسير للقران
بافكاره او اجتهادته باحترام رجل مقدر
ومحترم وله مكانته اكيد بس احنا نناقشه
معصوم ليس مقدسا ولا معصوما يعني كان فيه
حسن يؤثر على الجماهير يعني مش شخصيه تقول
منعزل في مكتبه او منزله يعني كاريزما حتى
الان يعني عايز اقول لك في وجدان الشعوب
اسمه
اعلى من كثير من المطربين والممثلين يعني
دي حقيقه